there is a delicate difference between
documentary short subjects and
documentary features that difference is
length in short the feature-length
nominees are the Lion King the Al
Hirschfeld story
Suzanne W dry foods Mandela Joe minnow
and Angus Gibson Suzanne Farrell
illusive news and Bell and Deborah Dixon
tell the truth in run George Sally's and
the American press Rick Goldsmith
when we were kings leon gassed and david
Sonnenberg my colleague in this
enterprise will now reveal the winner
the Oscar goes to when we were Kingsley
on gas and Davidson
what
Wow it's a miracle for us I want to
thank my wife Shelly who I love and
adore my children everybody back in room
318 at the Beverly Hills Hotel oh I
couldn't get in here my mother and
father my sister Janet Brian my in-laws
Anna uh everyone at fast communications
my friends everyone at Gramercy Allan
levy Michael [ __ ] Russell Schwartz
Claudia gray Howard Bingham Muhammad Ali
Lonnie Ali this is a film
this is a film about an incredible man
and it was directed by a man with a
great heart Leon gassed thank you very
much thank you David thank you for being
with me for all every second of the 23
years I want to thank my wife Jerry my
best friend George Foreman for being who
he was back then and who he is now
Robert one flesh definitely believing
him - Stewart Levine and the man the man
who realized a long while ago that he
could make a difference and he got bold
of his life to making a difference and
as President Bill Clinton said it's
about time that we as Americans start
paying him back for everything
Mohammed Ali
Oh
you